Alley we're here at the London comic-con
the MCM Expo what are the fans been
asking you about while you've been here
oh so many questions mostly um what
happened the last two times and I was
supposed to come I'd booked a couple of
movies so I wasn't able to attend the
last two but we finally got here and I'm
really happy to be here but they've been
asking about any of your characters in
particular oh yes I play lightning in
Final Fantasy 13 and the artist Sony and
Mass Effect I think those are pretty
much the two most popular roles that I
play right now but I also do a show
called Naruto I play the crazy cutting
in Naruto and yeah I get a few questions
about more you know kind of less popular
games that are that are just coming out
now like Kid Icarus I did the return of
Kid Icarus I played palutena in that
what else have I signed oh so many
things we've done a lot of signing today
so but I'm a bit worn out I'll admit and
what is it about those characters you
think that makes them so popular um well
I think that we're seeing a rise in
female characters in gaming who are not
sorcerers or mistresses or you know
we're getting some really strong female
characters and so I think that
especially with lightning and Liara
women especially relate to them a little
bit because they're layered characters
but they're strong characters and
they're not victims and also I think I
think the men enjoy that too it's it's
funny when when we see some drawings of
characters and and certain
embellishments of body parts even a lot
of the guys are like you know that's not
right for lightning she's she's a tough
girl so we don't we don't really want to
see her like that and I appreciate that
is it important to you than to playing
these kind of strong female roles in the
video gaming world because it's kind of
such a male-dominated thing in terms of
characters often and also in terms of
the players isn't term it is I think it
has been very male-dominated in the past
but I think the last few years we girls
are getting out there I was really
excited when Final Fantasy 13 came out I
started to see pink controllers
so I was like that's nice okay we're
trying to bring bring more ladies into
this and and also welcome them and let
girls know that that games are for them
as well and you've been playing a few
more military characters of late I think
have I knew yes I have I can't give any
secrets away but actually I will
announce and have announced recently a
game called fused by insomniac I'm very
excited to be a part of fuse the one
female female teammate which makes me
happy and yes there are a few others
coming out that I can't talk about but
you can make your guesses very exciting
can't wait to find out a little bit more
about those now when you do a military
role is there a lot of kind of having to
get into the zone because you've got to
get kind of psyched up how do you do
that that's a really good question I
feel like in any game it's for me my my
craft is I come at it from an actor's
point of view I don't come at it from a
voice point of view what does this
character sound like I come at it from a
presence sort of idea if that makes
sense who is the character behind the
microphone not what does she sound like
so a lot of times it's as if when I'm in
this sound studio it's as if I'm acting
in front of a green screen and the
directors you know letting me know that
things are blowing up and I always ask
them you know is this heightened is this
is there a lot of combat going on in the
war games because yeah we have to get
into it it's a great question a lot of
times I'll be running in place while I'm
doing my role or voicing or just
whatever needs to happen to put yourself
in the place of really honestly being
exhausted really honestly being in pain
and and it's it's not always easy but
much like on camera when we're shooting
film you know before the camera rolls
you're just standing there with your
coffee in your hand but as soon as they
yell action you've got to be there so I
do exactly the same thing really for
film that I do for voiceover just um
create the feeling instead of just make
it sound like I'm tired I really get
tired
no it's a little bit different than
doing on-camera stuff though is it
because you don't have necessarily
someone there to react to what you are
doing or you don't necessarily have the
whole set around you set up with the
location so you know what it looks like
in fact sometimes you don't even you
haven't got any artwork have you so how
does that work for you again great
question
I think that's where the craft of acting
really comes in because you're right
there's nothing to react off of and a
lot of us are taught that acting is
reacting and if you're reacting off of
nothing I'm not sure that that's really
good acting um but we really do yeah we
with the directors help we really do
have to create the scenario in our heads
and and really put ourselves in the
situation but you're right it's it's not
easy to do that and and I think
sometimes it helps sometimes I'll ask
the director can you read that line to
me like in Mass Effect a lot of times I
got to hear Jennifer Hale who plays the
female commander shepard and i I read
with her a lot because a lot of times
she was recording before me in Los
Angeles
Marc Mir who plays the male Commander
Shepard he wasn't around as much and
sometimes she had recorded before him so
I got to ask you know hey can I can I
hear her line and so I'd really get to
hear what she said for real and feel the
emotion of it so that I can use you know
Lee Aras character and react
honestly off of off the line instead of
again like you said sort of reacting off
of thin air I think with a final fantasy
that you did have some of the artwork
and stuff there that you were able to
see that and also the the the voice the
Japanese voice as well yes we did for
Final Fantasy we had all of the art it
was finished in Japanese so I really
liked that because I just I got to see
what lightnings face was doing before I
voiced her so that could give me a
little bit of an idea of what Square
Enix was looking for and also being able
to hear it already in Japanese by the
amazing voice actress who did it she I
don't understand a lick of Japanese
honestly I'm sorry but she was really
good and I could I could just feel what
she was feeling and
and get an idea of how they directed it
in Japan so that Jack Fletcher who was
our director on Final Fantasy when he
directed me I'm taking all of these
things into consideration lightnings
look and the emotions drawn in her face
by the artists were unreal it's a great
game and and then the Japanese voice and
then you know so there was a lot to work
off of but in Mass Effect we had nothing
so just the guidance of the directors
Jenny McSwain for Mass Effect 1 and then
Caroline Livingston from Bioware
directing us from Canada and we're
recording in Los Angeles
so she's just in my head and I have I'm
by myself I'm sorry and by myself in a
little recording studio with an engineer
and that's it so and no picture no
nothing I had originally just a little
sketch drawing of Liara I really didn't
even know what she looked like
so that takes it takes a good director
and a lot of listening Anna Cory actor
as well definitely I think yeah you have
to be able to roll with the punches for
sure and I think it's obviously a very
different experience than when people
are playing the game they obviously have
no idea that's all been going on it's
been someone down the line talking to
you in your ear and you've been kind of
getting in the zone and doing all that
kind of stuff I mean you gave me
yourself before you even started doing
the voice acting for the games I played
when I was younger played a lot of games
as a kid but as I you know started into
the acting business I really didn't have
any more time for television or much of
anything but work work work work work
and just now I'm starting to get back
into it
you know I've played a little Final
Fantasy played a little Mass Effect
played a little Starcraft 2 even tried a
little kiddie chorus but the little
screen a little hard for me um but just
getting back into it but honestly I I
worked so much in in gaming that
sometimes you know it's just at the end
of the day I just want to open a book
I can appreciate that you wouldn't get
away here and work thank you differently
I know well deserve whatever tour as
well yeah it feels like it yeah our any
character sir over the issue
particularly enjoy playing and are there
other ones that you think I'd really
like to maybe try out that type of
character because that's not one that I
normally can't um well I
I could play again we keep repeating the
same characters but I love the levels
and the layers of personality and
lightning and Liara I love that they
both had a struggle they both been hurt
in the past and have had to grow through
that so I think I could play either of
those characters again and again and
there are rumors that I might be playing
some more so we'll see no no but uh the
new military characters I'm having a
great time with too because it's great
to go into this sort of tough realm
where you're just the only girl of the
guys and and those so far the response
in those that I cannot mention has been
really good and one of the games they
even actually expanded my character so I
was very excited about that I wish I
could tell you what they are let's see
what else you know it wouldn't be bad I
think it'd be kind of fun sometimes I
tend to play the really tough girls
which I like and in real life I guess
I'm kind of a I guess a tough girl at
heart but it might be fun someday to
play a softer well er has got her soft
side Wow I don't know I don't know I'm
pretty happy I'm pretty happy with what
I've been doing let's get to here we're
happy that you're doing and continue
doing it forever we hope thank you yeah
if I can keep getting through my days of
being sawed in two and and shot and set
on fire and all these things if at the
end of the day I still want to go back
for more than then I think you'll
probably be hearing a lot more from me
you